[Clock ticking]
VOICE
Hello, and welcome to Staying Awake.
STEVEN
I have a sleeping disorder.
I can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams.
VOICE
Hello, and welcome to Staying Awake...
[Voice echoes, repeats]
STEVEN
[Screaming]
♫ Day and night ♫
♫ In my mind ♫
STEVEN
I'm losing it.
♫ Day and night ♫
DONNA
Real catch you are.
You're bloody useless, Stevie.
STEVEN
It's Steven.
DONNA
[Laughs]
STEVEN
I can't tell the difference...
...between life and dreams.
[Steven gasps]
[Screams]
[Elevator dings]
ELDERLY WOMAN
Thank you.
STEVEN
Lost a contact lens.
ELDERLY WOMAN
Hope you find it.
STEVEN
Thanks.
[Phone ringing]
♫ Hold the phone ♫
♫ Now hold the phone ♫
STEVEN
Yeah?
LAYLA
Oh my God, you're alive.
What's wrong with you, Marc?
STEVEN
Why did you call me Marc?
♫ Day and night ♫
ARTHUR HARROW
It must be very difficult.
The voices in your head.
MARC
Shut! Up!
ARTHUR HARROW
There's chaos in you.
[Screaming]
ARTHUR HARROW
Embrace the chaos.
♫ Day and night ♫
♫ At, at, at night ♫